(upbeat music)
- All right, I'm back with
late night host, Lilly Singh!
(audience cheers)
And you all know my next
guest as the super naturally
sensual vampire, Stefan,
that's how I know him,
of Vampire Diaries, but now he's starring
in a twisted fairytale thriller,
"Tell Me a Story" on CBS All Access.
You all take a look.
- Good morning.
Bad dream?
I hope you don't mind, but I
borrowed some of your clothes.
- You drugged me.
- Kind of messes with
your head, doesn't it?
- What are you still doing here?
You gonna kill me?
- Yeah.
(applauding)
Give it up for Paul Wesley, ya'll.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- Hello.
- How you doing?
Nice to meet you.
How's it going?
- Have a seat.
- Where do I sit?
Okay.
- You sit over here.
- Hi guys.
All right.
- Hello.
- Hi, hi.
Have you ever met Lilly?
- I don't think so.
- No, we're meeting now.
- How you doing?
- So nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you.
- You have great eyes.
- You know you have great eyes too.
I used to walk around New York City
and see your billboard's everywhere,
and I'd be like, "Who's this Lilly Singh?"
And now here you are,
so nice to meet you.
- I love you.
Thank you.
(laughing)
Yes, thank you.
- You're everywhere.
- She's killing it.
- Do you remember?
You know what I'm talking about.
- Tell me more.
- She knows what I'm talking about.
- She's killing it.
Tell me more, I'm amazing.
(laughing)
- This is about you.
- No, she's killing it.
No, but do you remember we met
years ago?
- Yes, I do.
- I was on tour.
- Yes.
- You visited us.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- In Atlanta.
I don't think you knew I was a real fan.
- Yeah, I didn't and I'm very flattered.
- Yep, yep.
- That's so great.
- And then you walked by
and I was like real quiet about it,
like low key.
- I know.
- I was like, "What up Stefan?"
I love that show.
I thought the chemistry was so great.
The writing was so cool.
- Thank you.
- I love anything and all vampires.
Were you ever into vampire stuff?
- I feel like everyone's
into vampire stuff
because vampires are factually hot.
- Seriously.
- No, then didn't use to be.
- No, they've always been.
- Did you ever see that?
- What?
- Remember that William
Dafoe movie, "Nosferatu."
Do you know what I'm talking about?
- I do.
- I'm actually a William--
- He was like a creepy old weird.
- I am oddly attracted to William Dafoe.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You know what,
I saw "Boondock Saints.
- I'm attracted
to him as well.
- And I was like to Ken, I was like,
"This guy's seriously odd, but hot."
- Yeah, yeah.
I like him too.
I can see that.
- Yeah, great actor.
- He's a great actor.
Vampires are sexy.
I'm just gonna let you
be wrong on that one.
Okay.
Well, explain to me though
because I loved the clip.
It was so scary and I'm so into it.
- [Paul] Oh, "Tell me a story."
- Yeah, "Tell me a story."
Tell me about it.
- Listen, it's a show.
We're on our second season,
and it's a show that
takes beloved fairytales.
This year we have "Sleeping Beauty",
we have, oh my gosh.
Whatever, we have "Sleeping Beauty".
Last year I did "The Three Little Pigs."
And he takes these fairytales
and modernizes them
and it puts them in a modern context.
So last year "The Three Little Pigs"
are three bank robbers
that put on pig masks.
They accidentally kill a woman.
Her husband wants revenge.
He becomes the big bad wolf.
It takes the archetype and
the story of the fairytale,
but puts it in a modern day
and twists it into a thriller.
- This is literally
written for me and my heart
and my brain.
- Yeah, you gotta watch it.
- I love when they do,
even like Gregory Maguire books,
like when he did wicked,
he turns the story.
- Well, that's exactly it.
- I love that kind of vibe.
He did the same thing with "Cinderella"
and the step sisters.
- So that's the general
premise of "Tell me a story"
and it's really good.
This year I'm in the
"Sleeping Beauty" storyline.
- I know I kind of gathered from the clip.
She was like, "Yeah, what's
it like to be drugged?"
Like you were just asleep.
Oh my gosh, I love you so much.
I cannot wait to watch "Tell me a story".
- Thank you.
- You all can check out
Paul in "Tell me a story"
streaming now on CBS All Access.
We will be right back.
(applauding)
(upbeat music)